[Música]
i
bueno misiones es una provincia única
para todo lo que se refiere a naturaleza
animales plantas somos una provincia que
realmente tiene todo en lo que se
refiere a biodiversidad la provincia con
más animales y diversidad de plantas y
animales de todo el país y en el mundo
somos una maravilla
entre un montón de especies que tenemos
acá algunas de ellas son emblemáticas
algunas de ellas son más importantes que
otras lamentablemente porque se
encuentran en peligro de extinción
esto qué afecta a las especies es motivo
por la cual por el cual muchas personas
instituciones de todo tipo estudian a
los animales para saber qué problemas
tienen cuántos hay cómo hacer para
protegerlos cómo hacer para que cada vez
estén más y principalmente saber qué es
lo que está haciendo que cada vez haya
menos
cuando estas personas intentan estudiar
a los animales que tenemos en nuestra
selva el principal problema en el cual
con el cual se topa en el cual tienen
que hacer frente es justamente la selva
porque yo digo esto porque
no es lo mismo estudiar un animal en
cualquier otro lugar
por ejemplo para no ir muy lejos en
corrientes donde podemos ver a distancia
donde podemos saber que hay en los
campos a hacerlo aquí en la selva
las células de misiones de una selva
subtropical que nos presenta un paredón
verde en frente que nos corta la vista a
escasos metros y tranquilamente podemos
tener un ave que nos está cantando a
tres metros de distancia y por más de
que nos esforcemos y por más de que la
busquemos no nos va a dejar ver la
podemos caminar por la selva y pasar a
dos metros de un yaguareté y nosotros ni
siquiera nos vamos a enterar eso es así
y ese es el problema principal en el
cual se encuentran los biólogos los
investigadores que tratan de conocer las
densidades de población de las especies
que ellos buscan así que
hay una forma más allá de ver a los
animales que permite conocer qué hay
adentro que se esconde dentro de la
selva y para que sepamos de todo todo lo
que es de lo que estoy hablando los
invito a ver este pequeño vídeo
este es un sector de la selva de
misiones
que se prolonga por kilómetros son
kilómetros y kilómetros de selva y si
nosotros fuéramos guardaparques o
biólogos o investigadores de la
naturaleza querríamos saber qué hay ahí
adentro qué animales hay cuántos
yaguaretés hay si hay o no hay
yaguaretés si hay alguna especie
amenazada si no lo hay si hay cazadores
furtivos que están cazando animales y
hay gente que está cortando árboles
donde no se debe
y
bueno la única forma que tenemos porque
hoy en día se tiene para conocer eso es
caminar ahí adentro
meterse y caminar y caminar y caminar y
buscar indicios de esto que le estoy
contando eso cuesta mucho
y
lo único que podemos obtener son
conjeturas cosas que por ahí mediciones
indirectas de lo que realmente hay
adentro así que veamos el mismo vídeo
con una pequeña diferencia y vamos a
cambiar el panorama
es el mismo lugar con la única
diferencia de que ahora estamos
escuchando estas son grabaciones que se
hicieron allá adentro en la cual se
escuchan muchísimas cosas y cada vez se
va a escuchar más en función a cuanto
sepamos lo que estamos escuchando
alguien experto en aves puede
identificar casi con exactitud qué aves
hay ahí y hasta en qué cantidad podemos
saber si hay monos y a yaguareté si
escuchamos un disparo estamos 100%
seguros de que hay alguien cazando ahí
adentro si escuchamos una motosierra
estamos completamente seguro de que
están cortando madera en una reserva
donde no deben hacerlo
así que esto inspiró un trabajo que lo
que le vengo a contar en el cual
colaboró con instituciones que van
conformada por biólogos
y trabajamos en conjunto para poder
sostener estas especies y estudiarlas y
conocer y conocer cómo evolucionan en
sus poblaciones antes de contarle cómo
lo hacemos necesito contarles un poco la
historia de cómo llegué a estar donde
estoy ahora y trabajar en lo que hago yo
en el año 2012 me recibí de ingeniera en
electrónica cano vera en la facultad e
ingeniería y me fui a especializar
cuatro años más hice una carrera de
estudio de de más de 10 años en la cual
me especialicé en algo que no tiene
prácticamente nada que ver con esto en
absoluto pero durante estos 10 años yo
tenía algo fijo en la cabeza que era que
todo lo que aprendía y todo lo que
estaba viendo y aprendiendo nuevo iba a
buscar la forma de que sirva para
proteger los animales que tenemos
emisiones
así que en el año 2016 me recibo y por
más que tenía ofertas de hacer otras
cosas volvía a misiones
esta idea fija en la cabeza hoy en día
soy profesor en la facultad de
ingenierías y desarrollé nos creamos una
línea de investigación en la facultad
que se dedica a la creación a la
fabricación de tecnología para proteger
la fauna y uno de los primeros trabajos
que hicimos fue un programa para
detectar disparos de arma de fuego en
audios de trabajo lo presentamos lo
publicamos
funcionaba pero funcionaba en los
papeles funcionaban las computadoras
necesitaba de alguna forma que eso se
lleve a la práctica mostrar que
realmente se puede y fue así que
se huele un poco interesante esto porque
sin saber esto sin saber lo que yo
estaba haciendo un grupo de biólogos del
proyecto yaguareté en iguazú habían
comprado un montón de grabadores de
audio para conocer la casa furtiva en
las zonas naturales protegidas de
emisiones y habían puesto a todos esos
grabadores en la selva montón de
grabadores
después cuando terminaron todo el
proceso de grabación que duró meses
obtuvieron estos son los grabadores
están colocando 6 terabytes de datos en
un montón de discos estos hay terabytes
de datos que eran audios grabaciones son
15 mil 936 horas que para hablar en
datos más concretos son casi dos años de
audio eso ellos tenían que escucharlo
para buscar algo que dura menos un
segundo que es un disparo es algo
prácticamente imposible por más cantidad
de gente que quieras poner a escuchar un
audio no lo iban a poder hacer
así que no quedó otra que nos reunamos y
nos juntamos y nos pusimos a trabajar en
conjunto
fue algo novedoso esto no se había hecho
nunca así que tuvimos que hacer un
montón de pruebas para ver si el
programa que yo había hecho en la
computadora en mi oficina funcionaba en
la vida real
tuvimos que estudiar qué sonidos hay en
la selva para que son parecidos a
disparos que podrían afectar el
comportamiento el funcionamiento de mi
programa y encontramos que hay un montón
roturas de árboles animales que rompen
hasta cuadras cuando caminan pájaros
carpinteros que golpean tan fuerte la
madera que hacían que el programa los
confunda con disparos pero superamos
todo eso y en menos de dos meses de
trabajo terminamos de procesar esos 22
años de audio y el resultado fue
espectacular se detectaron un montón de
disparos 100% verificados y
lo pudimos hacer
y ahora les cuento otra experiencia otro
trabajo que más que trabajo a mí me
gusta llamarlos desafíos porque trabajar
escuchando la selva es algo que para mí
no es un trabajo sino que es algo es
algo hermoso pero el desafío es
encontrar lo que estamos buscando y en
este caso el desafío consistirá en
buscar monos aulladores rojos esta
especie es una especie de mono que
habita las célebres misiones y está en
peligro crítico de extinción que
significa que hay realmente muy pocos
muy muy pocos y encontrarlos en
extensiones muy grandes celo es algo muy
difícil así que los biólogos usaron la
misma el mismo concepto de poner
grabadores y buscarlos en los audios y
esta vez pusieron
cerca de 10.000 horas un montón de
grabadores que juntaron 10.000 horas de
grabación que es más de un año de
grabación así que nos pusimos a trabajar
nuevamente y desarrolle un programa que
en este caso detecta a los monos y bueno
también el trabajo conjunto entre
biólogos ingenieros dio sus frutos y el
programa logró detectar poblaciones de
monos donde no se creía que estaban y
fue un total éxito
así que bueno se preguntarán ahora cuál
es el siguiente paso de todo esto que
queda por hacer y ahora lo que estamos
haciendo es en la facultad
tratando de que todo esto que les conté
la detección de los monos la detección
de los disparos hacerlo de manera
realmente automática que sea algo que no
haya que colocar un grabador dejar los
meses y después procesar años de audio
sino que se realice directamente en la
selva para eso estamos trabajando en
placas que son de este tamaño que van a
ser adaptadas para poner en la selva en
la humedad con los insectos preparadas
para trabajar con las las condiciones
climáticas que hay acá dentro en la
selva y con un sistema de baterías
especiales y que se cargan con paneles
solares muy chiquititos puede funcionar
por años en la selva y va a contar con
antenas que están desarrollando alumnos
en la facultad
en caso de detectar por ejemplo un
disparo avisará instantáneamente a quien
corresponda un guardaparque policía el
dueño de una reserva de que ocurrió un
evento que está buscando lo va a poder
hacer una central directamente al
celular aún como un mensaje de whatsapp
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]